[Music]
and domino catering news by Osho pizzas
appear I find out why pizzas yummy yo
pizza hut stuffed crust perfect lo
Caesars hot and ready yes it's not
Little Caesars but that's why I knew
Monica was the one when she's like yeah
let's go Little Caesars instead of like
wanting to go to some [ __ ] food
you're like oh my god and I marry you
like bit the crust into a rings I know
slide this sign yeah she's house I
woulda liked it alright a bride and
groom ordered four hundred fifty dollars
of Domino's Pizza for their wedding meal
because they couldn't decide on food so
this couple in England ordered for fifty
dollars of Domino pizza because they
couldn't decide on a traditional wedding
breakfast I don't even knows I'm calling
weight and breakfast England I guess I'm
confused
so is this an actual breakfast no I
think it's just whatever food they
served at there I think it's a leftover
breakfast their reception yeah
so then victory British newlyweds
Victoria and Tom Brown and their guests
tucked into 30 large pizza boxes twenty
garlic breadsticks twenty boxes of
chicken strips twenty boxes of wedges
and plenty of obligatory garlic and herb
dip and this is the happy couple and we
I don't even mean that in a mean way cuz
look at how happy I meant it in the mean
way
yeah hey relatable all right now I
really want to know about their lives oh
my god wait there's a Domino's person
next to him I thought they're sitting at
their weddings these are two delivery
people having the left and they've
already eaten through it a nice life I
think the delivery people just invited
like really like if you because the
local branch said this is the largest
order like we're good for the week how
many pizzas thirty thirty large pita
chip that was probably a giant I feel
like maybe for the day day you know much
people like people need a lot of pizza
yeah so basically they couldn't figure
out what they wanted to eat so they so
the bribe as a joke said like hey what
if we just do you think Domino's would
do it and then it became a reality like
most you know memes now obviously these
people are heroes I think in this
country we pay way too much for way oh
yeah I feel like that money should go to
our childbearing and to our house or
like you gonna film set a you're serving
pizza like man that's a little bit
different cuz you're working you know
like what's well like like cuz something
I thought was actually interesting that
I learned like from Ryan he goes podcast
when Tim was on was like apparently with
weddings is like you don't actually eat
that costs because since everybody gives
you money as wedding gifts basically if
you have you have nice wedding guests
yeah that's true
but my apparently it's part of the
wedding custom for people to give you
money so like you're actually only
spending like maybe a few I really
custom I thought it was the the
daughter's parent Kennedy the dowry part
is like part of it in that case well
that's different customs old-school yeah
I feel like these days the the daughters
like families not feel like it right my
family though because I have heard of
that was some some friends families and
stuff I think it just depends on you
know who it is and what their
circumstances in Sid you have any
friends who are married here I mean
besides like Bart I don't think not in
this immediate building right now
trying to gauge like how our I guess
millennial weddings are now I mean I've
been to some Finland
oh sorry yeah I've been to some my
Latino wedding is most of them are like
they just split the cost between them
right I feel like that's pretty fair
like between like the two families are
not even between the two families I
think we're on the wave now to where
like weddings are coming back but not in
the grandiose way but it's more so of
getting married it's coming back as
opposed to like before the ceremony it's
that like that yeah where we went back
to like cuz yeah it's like we went from
everyone's like oh we gotta have
extravagant weddings to where they went
to all right but we don't need to get
married at all and we went through that
and then I feel like now people are like
oh let's get married but it's like it's
toned down it's something more I feel
like they're much more the trend now is
very what's the intimate necessarily but
it's definitely a lot more personable
like I feel like people like or at least
the weddings that I've seen like with
that are actually no I I do have some
forensic that got married pretty
recently late yeah they just had like a
small ceremony in like a local venue
that wasn't super crazy and then there
was like food and drinks afterwards but
none of it was yeah I think that he just
um you get has a connection with
goldenrod brewing so Wow Wow of course
food and stuff was catered from like a
taco company but yeah I mean that's cool
my friends who have been together for 15
years like the pretty much are you
married yeah they're waiting until they
buy a house burst and then they're gonna
have the reception in their backyard oh
yeah yeah money goes into you like how
things it's and then you have your sous
vide I've heard of people having
weddings in their house or whatever they
just have it well it's the people like
in the Midwest and stuff that have more
land right absolutely when they want to
dig that yard and do it actually no I
have a friend of Victorville they got
married in his backyard yeah yeah so I
mean it was Victor who's a larger I mean
I don't you know land is cheap he like
rented out cousin like wedding venues
charge way too much for no reason at all
right because they know that they can
yeah so she rents it out like a like a
like a house in like Massachusetts
because she's in the East Coast and it's
like few acres of land it was huge so
then she just had her wedding outside in
like the fields and then like then she
had the reception in the ball
which was [ __ ] a sick yeah so I've
been everyone had to go I would had a
fight there though was white-shoe her
they turned the barn into like a like a
nice area so what it Dwight Schrute he's
like now entering nothing doing well
yeah definitely I feel like just the
cost of weddings and the up charge for
everything is just down for like a
quarter what anything in court wedding
you just want the legal kind of guy yeah
because it just doesn't make sense did
you do you do you want any sort of
reception after the same way we the same
way we're just going to go if we ever do
it we just walk in the ladies don't want
that right or just Monica did you not
get also down for not having a huge
[ __ ] I guess the issue though that
she hasn't cooked up so is it worth five
dollars of my time thanks what's the
most you guys have ever spent on pizza
and pizza like me personally I go eat
with these guys oh yeah purgatory I
could get three large like pizza pizzas
or [ __ ] six Little Caesars Pizza
compared to my favorite book is [ __ ]
cost oh yeah good that makes a good
pizza
I like the trying to make bad pizza to
me real honestly unless you have those
those school lunches okay so there's a
very cuz that is some dry like shitty
crossing stuff that's like the school
lunch that's the school obviously I like
school Peter he's going I like I so love
school wait what
as long as he didn't burn the the crust
because you know it's crazy they have
the one with the [ __ ] cheese in the
crust the end they get like the cheese
loaded in the cross isn't that stuff
correct yeah yeah
it's like alien pizza or something like
that I don't remember like where they
got it from a natural place no I think
when they're thinking of school pizzas
they're thinking of like the ones they
make at the school no it is made at the
school cuz they but they just buy it
frozen or whatever from whatever food
supply company yeah and they just got
pizza and like yeah every week we would
have to do like a ton of keeps like 30
pizzas and over to the school's awesome
you worked at Pizza Hut yeah yeah what's
some drama what would happen back there
what's them something would do to pizzas
sauce all right no no Mike I said you go
to that head stuffed crust yeah bread
would never in my element with the Brit
would write would okay what do I know
wondering what a Brit would know no
bright wit it's a lot it's like down the
street from okay we had stuff Chris
pizzaaaa way Marina del Rey had large
slice pizza dude thank God no one can
relate to you guys right now
the cast starts talking about oh yeah
that place on that landing and blah blah
oh no no no it's actually on this I miss
these streets and I'm like sure the
Casper street names like first of all on
the 66 do Oh like I don't [ __ ] care
where Valley is right
what would you skip on on your weddings
I was not obviously I wouldn't do it for
pizza [ __ ] plus ones like crazy crazy
plus ones like if I don't if I've never
met you you're not coming to my wedding
yeah yeah crazy yeah what am I crazy
blossom like you look like a like a like
quinceanera right anyone shows up today
that's a little different that's like a
plus five you know I feel like everyone
can have a plus-one but I'm not gonna
invite that many people so like what was
my party gonna double like what did we
come by for people just I feel like
everybody just gets one like all the
people that I invited you just get like
you know you're one right like oh I have
to pick I guess it's like a pity invite
you're really not getting on plus-one
well they don't pity they just don't
invite him actually if they're already a
couple you don't get a plus
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah if you idiot
you're coming with a couple yeah that's
it you you were eight this is your
chance yeah you know if I'd have to pay
per head I feel like I'd actually want
to have a ton of people to the point
where they don't bother me even with my
wedding like how does that work all my
people come in to your table and be like
congratulations yeah I don't want to be
so small that I learn I have to go in
there do this tower thing I learned
enough to where everybody's set up here
interacts with each other
so me and my bride could just act a fool
and then just what didn't leave
everybody so busy I've been to big
weddings where the bride or the bride
and groom it is no good bill it's like a
thing where you have to like walk around
all the tables and say hi there's a lot
of times you can give some these people
to so you need to say like you know
thank you and stuff so it's gonna be
kind of shitty if you're just like you
don't say anything anybody and then you
just and they give you gifts and any
peace out so that's I think that you
know trade-off but else it depends on
your kind of wedding like you might just
have a super non-traditional wedding
like I don't know with broken arm this
isn't my identity Ryan all right but
your brand now it is my brand new so it
was Nelson's Graham but no true
don't ride motorcycles guys oh my god
build you one